[Music]
during a long day spent roaming the
forest in search of edible grains and
herbs the weary divine farmer shannon
accidentally poisoned himself 72 times
but before the poisons could end his
life a leaf drifted into his mouth
he chewed on it and it revived him
and that is how we discovered tea
or so an ancient legend goes at least
tea doesn't actually cure poisonings but
the story of shen nong the mythical
chinese inventor of agriculture
highlights tea's importance to ancient
china
archaeological evidence suggests tea was
first cultivated there as early as 6000
years ago or 1500 years before the
pharaohs built the great pyramids of
giza that original chinese tea plant is
the same type that's grown around the
world today yet it was originally
consumed very differently it was eaten
as a vegetable or cooked with grain
porridge
tea only shifted from food to drink 1500
years ago when people realized that a
combination of heat and moisture could
create a complex and varied taste out of
the leafy green
after hundreds of years of variations to
the preparation method the standard
became to heat tea pack it into portable
cakes grind it into powder
mix with hot water and create a beverage
called muacha or matcha
matcha became so popular that a distinct
chinese tea culture emerged
tea was the subject of books and poetry
the favorite drink of emperors and a
medium for artists they would draw
extravagant pictures in the foam of the
tea very much like the espresso art you
might see in coffee shops today
in the 9th century during the tang
dynasty a japanese monk brought the
first tea plant to japan
the japanese eventually developed their
own unique rituals around tea
leading to the creation of the japanese
tea ceremony and in the 14th century
during the ming dynasty the chinese
emperor shifted the standard from tea
pressed into cakes to loose-leaf tea
at that point china still held a virtual
monopoly on the world's tea trees making
tea one of three essential chinese
export goods along with porcelain and
silk
this gave china a great deal of power
and economic influence as tea drinking
spread around the world
that spread began in earnest around the
early 1600s when dutch traders brought
tea to europe in large quantities
many credit queen catherine of braganza
a portuguese noblewoman for making tea
popular with the english aristocracy
when she married king charles ii in
1661.
at the time great britain was in the
midst of expanding its colonial
influence and becoming the new dominant
world power
and as great britain grew interest in
tea spread around the world
by 1700 tea in europe sold for 10 times
the price of coffee and the plant was
still only grown in china
the tea trade was so lucrative that the
world's fastest sailboat the clipper
ship was born out of intense competition
between western trading companies
all were racing to bring their tea back
to europe first to maximize their
profits
at first britain paid for all this
chinese tea with silver
when that proved too expensive they
suggested trading tea for another
substance opium
this triggered a public health problem
within china as people became addicted
to the drug
then in 1839 a chinese official ordered
his men to destroy massive british
shipments of opium as a statement
against britain's influence over china
this act triggered the first opium war
between the two nations
fighting raged up and down the chinese
coast until 1842 when the defeated ting
dynasty ceded the port of hong kong to
the british and resumed trading on
unfavorable terms
the war weakened china's global standing
for over a century
the british east india company also
wanted to be able to grow tea themselves
and further control the market
so they commissioned botanist robert
fortune to steal tea from china in a
covert operation
he disguised himself and took a perilous
journey through china's mountainous tea
regions eventually smuggling tea trees
and experienced tea workers into
darjeeling india
from there the plants spread further
still
helping drive teas rapid growth as an
everyday commodity
today tea is the second most consumed
beverage in the world after water and
from sugary turkish rizza tea to salty
tibetan butter tea there are almost as
many ways of preparing the beverage as
there are cultures on the globe
[Music]
you